(TV static)
(Netflix logo droning)
- Wait is Dale Winton the one
who did Supermarket Sweep?
Ugh.
When I was in (mumbles)
me and my housemates
used to play Supermarket Sweep.
The security guard at
Tesco's would be like,
"You need to stop,
because this is too much."
My name's Mason.
I grew up on the border of Suri.
I grew up in a village that's
super duper tiny called
(mumbles).
Two trains an hour.
So now I live in
a place (laughs) I can't
pronounce, Llanelli.
Every single Welsh person's
gonna kill me for that.
I truly love Wales, it's
so much fun to be here.
I think the first time I
maybe even thought I was gay
I think it was Dylan.
Dylan was my sexual awakening.
Dylan from Casualty.
I must have been about eight years old.
That's Dylan.
That beautiful, blonde, absolute stunner.
I think he died in the
end, I think he was shot.
And I didn't watch it ever again.
So I came out to Mum,
I was 18 at the time.
I went home and I said,
"Mum, let's have a chat."
And she said to me, "Do I have
to turn the TV off for this?"
I said, "Yeah, yeah, turn it off."
And she just went to
me, "Do you like boys?"
Yeah, and she was like,
"Fantastic, are you in for dinner?"
That was it.
It was like short conversation.
I fully expected some sort of party.
I wanted balloons, everything.
There's an episode of Ugly
Betty and Justin comes out.
They fully give him a pinata,
there's rainbows and everything,
and I was like, "That's
what coming out is,"
and I got absolutely none of it.
Christian from Eastenders,
that was a different kind
of vibe for me though,
because he was a fair
amount older than me,
secondly he's got huge
muscles, tiny head though.
He was just so masculine.
It made me challenge my
own stereotypes of gay.
When you're younger you're drawn to people
because you look for guidance in society.
You are given cues.
Now I'm 24, I look more
towards queer media
than I do towards straight
media for those kind of cues.
When I was younger
Facebook wasn't a thing.
It was Bebo.
The greatest social media
network of all time.
It was there that I first saw
anything from Queer as Folk.
Was like, "Ah, gay people?
But this is TV!"
It was a real chance to
learn about gay culture,
'cause I had never been to a gay bar
before my first year of uni.
And it fully thrusts you into that world.
Representation is one of
the biggest driving forces
into more people being
accepting and educating,
and TV is the best way to do that.
I truly believe RuPaul's Drag Race
is the most diverse representation on TV
that you can find.
Queer men, the occasional
trans person, black people,
white people, Latinos, people
who speak different languages,
and the whole thing is a message of love.
Also you can follow the
journey, it doesn't end.
That's the best part I think,
because the show ends and
you just get to follow them.
Like Trixie and Katya, I loved them
and now they've got their own show
and I can watch all the time.
Sex Education is really
good, and it's in Wales.
You see the relationship between a gay man
and a straight boy,
but they're best friends.
When I was younger more so,
it was always like the thing, "Ew, no,
you're gonna try and sleep with me."
And I'm like, "No."
"You may be a boy,that doesn't
mean I wanna sleep with you."
Seeing representation like that on TV
it allows for straight guys to
not receive as much weirdness
from their other friends.
For me, as a mixed race gay man,
it's difficult to find a protagonist.
Which is weird because I mean,
I'm pretty sure there's quite a few of us.
The closest I get to be
like, "Oh, we're the same,"
Is Justin from Ugly Betty.
'Cause we were around a similar age,
he likes magazine, I like magazines.
He's gay, I'm gay.
The only difference is that
he got a pinata and I didn't.
Like that's pretty much
the only difference.
When Pose came out, I was
like, "Oh, this is great!"
So many black people,
so many people of color,
everyone's gay, everyone's trans.
It's just so good.
And also it's like a great TV show.
Which I think is important,
because you can have a whole load
of gay people make a TV show,
but if it's not any good
people aren't gonna watch it,
people aren't gonna pay attention.
The more people that watch,
the more people that are educated,
the more people that learn.
And everyone's really
attractive on that show.
Like weirdly attractive,
it's somewhat annoying.
(uplifting orchestral music)